hey what's up you making that cool face
that you make again yes we are back with
residue six I figured it'd be funny
maybe every episode this series okay to
see if you can recap what's happening in
this story because people seem to like
when you give your opinion about these
games and I want to see if you remember
what was happening okay so you want me
to to recap what happened so try to
explain the story of resmio six so far
okay all right um okay that's actually
really hard
it's like mostly explosion based an
explosion based shooter okay
after the epilogue prologue epilogues
come at the end of all right after the
provable time yes okay so I shot the
president in the head and we went
through all his stuff and then a dude
came out looking for his daughter yeah
and she was a dead person so she died
and then a bunch of zombies came out and
that guy died and then and then we went
through the university escape to the
sewer then we got to the sewer here we
are I think that's it
did I miss anything important I could
not tell you I was gonna say we were in
a helicopter and then the guy died Oh
Mikey yeah at first we had a Mikey deaf
people seem to take joy in him dying
that early in the game did you change
the scene to this just wanna make sure
you did sorry what from a full screen of
you and me to the video game yeah yeah
okay I wasn't paying attention now you
guys let me double check
I'm sorry absolutely sure oh the last
thing that happened was I ran down here
and said spoiler
who looked for his boiler I didn't find
any a box
no smoking okay all right cool so
looking through the comments last time
ya know dude obviously was not helpful
because just as many people said we
should play Jake's campaign as people
said we should just stick to these two
my butts all wet so I don't know what to
think of that how do you its points yeah
I can't swim doesn't matter
Oh remember Leon said not a fan of
sewers oh did he yeah there's some
probably some loot over here for you I
don't know what you're seeing it's cool
that we don't have to fight over it yeah
cuz yeah there was a time when we did
hey do we spend those points and when do
we spend those points were we supposed
to spend them before we started sorry
which experience that's electricity it's
actually a good question I completely
forgot I know you can equip skills on
your smartphone if you bring up the
touch pad right now and then you go to
equip skills that bottom left on the
Pentagon I don't know okay maybe we
haven't learned yet yes oh this parts so
fun I hate this part fun I feel like you
were gonna say fun but then you were
like oh what did you get oh you and your
cuted Leon look at me it's it's quite
shocking how bad this game can be how
did you get electrocuted
it's only when it's in the water right
yeah but also get ready for QuickTime
stuff zombie coming at us okay can we
get him electrocuted I don't think is I
think the electrocution was literally
just to keep us from going that
direction
hi you might boo did you tell him to eat
your poop but somebody said that to me
on the internet once eat my poop yeah I
said um that's a bad explanation and I
don't agree with you either
you should have said with pleasure
and then just send him a photo of you
covered in [ __ ] it's pretty smart
ok-ran yeah fire actually he was not
using you're getting stompy are -
apologies my mic sounds really low and I
think it was last episode a little bit -
but I don't think it's that big of
problems you guys probably don't I have
to be careful because I
oh [ __ ] I feel like it's low but then
I'm like oh that's cool
[ __ ] [ __ ] get off the tracks oh no the
track
I don't think I press the right button I
press everything and also there was a
bunch of skin in my shot was that your
arm yep I'm gonna tell you like we were
talking about this a little bit before
we started but I don't want to ruin it I
want to capture my honest feelings about
this
currently I genuinely I I'm having more
fun than I did with ya re5 that's the
thing it's it's almost like I know re
five is known as being the shot like dog
sorry can I not kick this dog yeah re
six is known as the bad one and re five
is kicking these dogs I don't feel good
about it
anyway I don't know re five I'd like
some of the like really boring boss
fights and it's characters weren't
memorable it's like this one's dumb but
at least it's like to its credit fund um
he goes for it more than five s five
kind of hesitates between the old and
new resume yeah this one's like
committed to its its weirdness so and
the animations are really cool like when
I smash that guy's head on a railing and
this one I ripped an axe out of someone
oh [ __ ] can I save this guy I cannot the
president again Paul
now you touch bad you got that weird
thing up
oh the left side of it oh it's a weird
thing we have to do I
it's something like you know you can go
in there we can yeah well they can they
come out of there I was just telling
Mary how I find it funny that I didn't
realize until I went back and like I try
to watch these every once in a while but
I also try to avoid Mary over the
weekends so but I I turn I put this
episode on YouTube up like a few days
ago and I only just noticed that it just
plays my gamertag for everyone to see
right there well I don't think it helps
that you tell everyone well I mean it's
glowing green I think I just get it
cuted what's the plan here and I said
gamertag another yes an idea where they
call it well that guy's electrocuted
what was your patters what was your
first gamertag Catman 922 that's so good
um so do you want to hear the origins
actually that's funny but I don't are
you kidding me what that guy through an
axe from like a mile away and it wasn't
even looking like it was gonna hit me
and it did triple barrel shotgun that's
kind of cool
wait where'd you get that it's just one
of my weapons oh you have another weapon
don't you you should press the left oh
the d-pad you don't have another weapon
no I have an incendiary grenade I'll
pick more often a first-aid spray a
remote bomb ramones I do not have you do
okay so I guess that's what happened oh
wait I do know I'm dumb okay so I don't
have it oh no no you know you have
someone pointed out on I have a knife
tube no you can also also aim with your
handgun uh-huh
[ __ ] and then press
triangle yeah this dish dish dish dish
how did I don't have that this is
exactly like loser craft I was laughing
you got run over by a train I think I
hear job these doors look the same as in
500 wheelies Dooley's it's good thing
you have a hundred 21 rounds run out
anytime soon you doing pretty bad after
that biker jacket and those things tight
slacks and I mean eatin these pills and
your eyeball check out it's like there's
three people now make double pistols
you're all in trouble man I'm sorry I
press the wrong button
well I press the right button I press it
the wrong time curb stomp boxes though
oh my god that was so cool wait do you
see how you put them away oh yeah yeah
yeah I twist them or anything [ __ ]
doc holliday them come on I wish you can
see my screen right now do it
I don't know how to do it are - no that
won't make sense is what how'd you hear
is there a way to put away your weapon
oh I'm super cool wait how'd you do that
that was reloading just switch press up
or down on the know it was reload
animation when I spin them like that
well shoot a couple rounds and do it
okay again doing the light alright check
it out
[ __ ] that's cool yeah we should see the
front of me oh I can't trust me it's
good sweet one more tall up station
kinda reminds me of blue emblem I loved
in Back to the Future it used to be
what's a fire that didn't unlock for you
as well I guess you don't it's not to me
um Twin Pines mall when he runs over the
tree later on when he comes back it
becomes Lone Pine
I don't know back to the future I saw a
tall oak station for some reason that
reminds me of uh looks cool that is so
cool
that's straight up just like that movie
28 days later does that like yeah when
they're in the car the tunnel with the
car no legs straight up yeah that's the
[ __ ] same okay get ready to dodge
trains son when right now they're gonna
see there's two tracks we're gonna
bounce back and forth between them and
go forward or yeah I just run forward I
would say so don't fight just well you
can if you want I think it's a waste of
resources by abbess dodge even run on
the tracks all right oh it's gonna come
from behind us [ __ ] on my face I think I
actually don't know just keep an eye out
I guess well you're distracting
everybody
[Music]
the Train is here check his pulse
sorry I thought that it was gonna give
me a prompt did it give you a prompt I
wasn't on the track so I don't know I
just kind of because we gotta keep an
eye behind us didn't give me a prompt it
sprint dude this is such a cool visual
this is exactly like what they did in 28
days later all right so
somebody's go to that track how do we
know which why don't you go friend
I wasn't fronty when he died
I don't understand what happened right
I'm not getting a proxy you don't need a
prompt I just don't go on the tracks
yeah like though that's don't walk into
a train is that what happened I'm not
getting a prompt either I'm just staying
on the all right you go first
you have to be pretty far from it like
don't go anywhere there like I said this
game is not good so no I think it will
happen I don't think this is a game I
just don't think I understand cuz I I
wasn't on the train oh [ __ ]
I'm coming alright get off the train
nope nope [ __ ] yeah just don't go over
there your find us but so then another
train comes I believe so yeah and that's
what hit me in the butt
probably yeah no we've got to get past
this fence though so we can go the other
side should we just do that now I'm not
positive to go from that side so we
might have to let's just pray that it
goes to the other side oh we might
already be there
that doesn't seem like a good thing it's
amazing a chain who always that was a
Carlos from resin what three remember
when you fought you want to that train I
remember that boom sue or something at
open yeah
actually what's it called resonable zero
the first half takes place right oh [ __ ]
why they they're right next to us just
don't leave me behind
sorry oh [ __ ]
oh that's so cool I'm so cool all right
I'm gonna be sure but yeah we have to go
down okay gotcha should heal oh yeah
you're on uh three diamonds especially
cuz I'm about to definitely get attacked
inside this train what where did you
come from that those are Dino inside the
squares okay I guess that's acceptable
also all squares are diamonds in a
different direction get it just kind of
rotate it you can't hear your audio oh
yeah are you then something you can hear
my gunshot to you then but I was Elena
is recounting a story I guess the show
might as well call it actually it's not
did you kill these people no they might
be alive stuff that girls don't he's
like the most generic scream a lady
looks fine alright
she just had just in case nope I'll be
so pissed if he wakes up when I walk on
that's from like years of Dark Souls
where you're like I'm gonna shoot that
just oh he did
oh they're so much
someone binary wait wait there was stuff
picking up stuff on the subway train
kind of things an actual that sounds
like actual lyrics nope
hey good-lookin suck it my mama told me
she had a nightmare on the L train oh I
need to get off now
oh that guy threw [ __ ] at me I'm not
doing so great over here just to lift
him in the chin that was cool train
train train train
there's no this train stopped this looks
like Bart no no no I guess it looks this
subway this does kind of look like a
Muni tripping over ba order are you
getting hurt no I'm just tripping over
bods Wayne comfort style is our middle
name like Bruce Wayne yes
Bruce style Wayne leave it to auto did
we talk yeah we talked about this that
was the mascot no we didn't talk about
it what is it otto was the mascot of I
remember Otto no we talked about it yeah
isn't Otto was that you and me we talked
about that was the the mascot for my
college I went to a lot of the orange we
talked about orange I remember cuz that
was like dumb and I was like your mascot
can't be orange yeah oh [ __ ] was that it
was Gary Jay
shut up you're dead
oh you'll never get out of here alive
doing this rate it was that simple
but okay this looks like it's modeled
after Munich on okay so he's invincible
just for the sake of that Capcom would
not let me you are dumb
I have a grenade should I use it oh they
hurt you through a firewall
what was that it was my grenade I guess
I didn't do everything I have actually
fired I have dual fired pistols oh wait
I'm covered in acid or something
what is that bile are they shooting [ __ ]
at us yeah oh that's cool mispronounced
I mean it's annoying but it's cool like
es bitters
oh [ __ ] all right let's get that [ __ ]
out of here
it's like a carrying I'll pull it [ __ ]
am I out of help are you behind you
I'm almost dead come on
oh wait I did the ping what are
conditions like up there here's a thank
you herbs I keeps him sorry I have to
jump back over and all these work come
on it's pretty cool going downtown
oh wait check this out you never seen a
buddy make you feel brand new let's oh
that's cool you gonna try to trying to
butt-fuck it away doesn't feel like Oh
check this out way I'm cheating the
subways at all ticket whoo wait a minute
I'm gonna [ __ ] with the UH look at it
look at it look at this slow it doesn't
know if I'm gonna go or not wait a
minute no wait wait wait come look no no
come here I'm coming I'm coming as fast
as I can
I'm coming just wait get over here
okay hold on wait yes you can roll my
back [ __ ] all right come in my back
it just hold on get over here
it's a weird spot for a loading hungry I
have these chips Oh Peter thank you
I brought sneaks a part of town to get
to the Cathedral really to trouble
really good point Oh Lord punk [ __ ]
like those bodybuilder guys you have to
like eat every few hours or ever and
they're like really annoying and they're
always trying to eat sushi because of
the protein I eat a lot of fish I rest
my case that's cool if you're a
drunk-driving we're gonna see you before
you see us that guy's alive you see that
that's pretty neat look at this guy this
guy's got green hair how come he's not
interested in hurting us
yeah he's more us in the car than eating
human flight over total nonsense it's
weird
see here there's a barrel music
cigarettes and I should be sprinting I
don't feel like
oh look at that I was actually helping
this dude what do you mean this guy is
helping has no legs Lieutenant ding
lieutenant damn I just pissed them off
all right Who am I helping this guy [ __ ]
is your problem
sabi Paco just automatically makes
everyone wasted let's go oh [ __ ]
SWAT people now there's a ladder up here
get on it
SWAT zombies was that mean like SWAT
members SWAT team members that have
since been zombified wearing all their
body armor and using mp5s wow this is
cool - this reminds me of like one of
those escape from zombies [ __ ] I need
your help not worked out I took care of
it I need your help just kidding did you
have the same animation that I did
everybody I would not be asking suction
oh that's cool I'm cool with this hey
hey [ __ ] pass health I was gonna say
asshat I said listen
hmm
get away from me you fire zombie it's
just not fun to shoot this shotgun now
should be put more fun it doesn't the
weapons don't have a kick in this game
like when you shoot them there's no
impact what I don't like need that
feedback did you get hurt yeah coming
Oh Joe Frank run walk I didn't know
zombies could shoot that sounds like a
Bailey school kids book zombies don't
shoot they're not supposed to I think
it's ridiculous there was that one
zombie film that like broke that
convention and let them shoot and it
pissed me off
actually it's happened a couple times I
think 28 weeks later let it happen and
land of the dead let it happen and both
of those I just don't agree with zombies
are supposed to be dumb they're not
supposed to
I think they let them swim too it's
blasphemy oh I'm being shot okay I got
shot a lot oh I'm down oh [ __ ] I jump
down it's okay I got back up why is
everyone drunk driving this person just
this person just backed the car up
basically into no over there oh that
[ __ ] you up everyone this reminds me
the beginning of resonable to hide in
this garbage can
way worse
I killed that guy hurry up
good idea it'd be safer if you keep
indoors as much as possible maybe we can
even catch our breath
check out these beers oh look at this
look at this what a ball I lost can you
move it
yeah just oh you're not on my screen
wanna [ __ ] it really yeah I am I might
be that's interesting now it looks like
it's my joke baki baktun ah what that
word bothers me so much
baton no no no no the the fridge on
behind bars rules what is a spool I
don't know but I want one now no just
saying that word makes me agitated
spruill I have to strain my vocal cords
to say that I'll take one sprue and a
lats rule for my wife I hate that
sprawls Oh Spruill the non-alcoholic
beer oh my god that looks like trash
another gun over there why is that
handgun shown on my screen I don't know
check it out he got yep [ __ ] called
it now I got a daughter
I got your skill points oh sweet we're
gonna bout to get a machine down oh
really
I think so okay we have to go through
this door oh [ __ ] man he must have been
watching something to a potential attack
why is he so real looking for his mouth
responsible Devon from the sushi
you know what I've started doing since I
started living in San Francisco as I
start walking in rooms and thinking like
what is this like 300 square feet it's
good because everything here is 100
square feet and $3,000 my apartment is
500 square feet which I didn't even know
you could get that small and I've seen
apartments bless them up maybe I mean
there's no proof of that
I don't know what makes you assume these
things well also Leon can telepathically
attract things or a control metal it was
just that guy this guy is a veteran of
the Raccoon City incident toothy Magoo
transistor all right you ready
what yup I don't and a trophy
say Vignola I like shopping I got a
shotgun now I'm ready to kick some butt
the Hydra is the shock on the shoes
sorry was I supposed to save that guy I
wonder if you're allowed to say his
people in this game I wouldn't know
because I'm saved anyone yet Bobby
please is he making out with them shoot
those costumes
they're climbing the fence shoot him in
the deck pursue that one chase that one
oh he's got a fire scene night Wow Oh
God oh [ __ ] not be near
oh I guess not they don't explode yeah
that one didn't that he like released a
fancy trophy okay you skill points to
purchase skills it's still baffling
because I don't skills what are those
it might be something we do they're
hanging from the ceiling that's pretty
funny that's like a haunted house style
do a spider-man kill are crazy like
leave him there don't even just leave
him
he's my favorite I want him right kill
him kill Toby
it's locked
get it open from the other side how can
her arm not fit through there to lift
that do you see what I'm are you looking
at the same door as me Elena you're weak
you're here too your children are weak
and you will not survive the winner the
power rangers reference [ __ ] did it
god damn circle oh you did I can't
believe you did like a full circle in
your jump oh come on
flip is that what you're trying to set
up for a circle somersault alright
[ __ ] out here oh no what do you mean
sorry I'm gonna die I know sorry the
animation I'm actually gonna die I know
the animation come to the dark the
animation to lift to unlock the door it
locks me the animation long
I got you I got you who come to the door
shut it wait wait wait there's the kill
point this is important oh if you killed
them all hold on I need to make a
triangle I need to make just combine all
those square square square and then you
combine those as well I can do that
that's cool
let's exhale the transit stop yum yum
mama needs her pills
I don't know yellow mustard tomato
ketchup it's oddly accurate oh look at
what we have here excuse me you have a
lost-and-found box I seem to have
forgotten my emblem or what I they call
them emblems right fire emblem
this reminds me of the third one so can
we save these people
we have a shotgun too
I should have done there oh I [ __ ]
took a pretty heavy hit
[Music]
oh you're getting stompy - he hurts you
screaming OH
I am super dead [ __ ]
what how did that happen through this
ambulance at us that it is impossible to
dodge maybe you were to kill him I think
we just yeah I guess or just get on the
way over
[Music]
yeah get out of that corner am I already
dead yeah let me know enemies but also
get out of the way that I don't I don't
all right let's get out of there see
that dude shoot that dude wait
the guys coming forget his screaming guy
[ __ ]
[ __ ] oh my god oh my god everybody well
that is no value Oh channels out of ammo
oh sweet the paramedics have guns inside
the ambulance now make that up and
magnums of course they do seem like
something paramedics with parries don't
you yet I will not
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay I'm about to do it no no
no no no no Ariane I'm doing it it's
getting don't douse yourself in it sorry
I don't think that would work like that
the spark wouldn't to pull it wouldn't
generate I'm thinking way too much cycle
turn my brain off I've heard about that
from movies that it's like you can't we
need a spark I believe well
guns like bullets going that speed
hitting metal couldn't create a spark
yeah that was that was liquid though
that was the actual gas it's flammable
it's not the actual metal ground or
something
this game isn't striving to be accurate
so I feel for you discussing us we had a
pilot take off and then be dead oh I
think I'm in real life it's like how how
have you not talked about that it's
terrifying one day I'll tell you no oh
wait are we dealing with survivors
there's a [ __ ] ton of guns in here can I
left that - oh they were spraying
mom literally leopard at two what do you
mean you get that six pack of soda for
the dude and the first campaign I
remember that but he's in a gun shop the
top he's locked in
all right lot of grenades over here as
you might have seen where his wife for
me at least I don't know I just look
around the edges I guess okay I got one
incendiary looks like that's in Chenzhou
grenade Oh for [ __ ] sake
that guy jumped super fast
Thanks what a stupid [ __ ]
do something okay good
actually I want them to kind of come
inside cuz we don't get the points I
didn't think about that
alright oh wait me so Dom Peters that
the husband that's not helping she's
terrible
like there's makings of greatness in
this but like we don't know these people
well enough to give a [ __ ] that's that
dude just suddenly four she's holding us
back about her girlfriend
Oh I mean you hasn't felt that way about
a significant other significant oh sweet
[ __ ] firemen firefighters wear
clothes Azzam be wrong
ooh you got spit on no I didn't owe that
police officer didn't call me a pig oh
you're in this other room yeah here come
two SWAT members okay
sorry it wasn't you
you wanted to come inside right or no
yeah but there were a lot over here so I
figured I'd kill a couple yeah you're
also an [ __ ] you idiots could fight
it out if you want that guy's got a
bright future ahead of him and wait for
him to die it's gonna be dope diggity
diggity
so should we leave no because it looks
like I can like oh no I can't I thought
I could leave [ __ ] he didn't he
didn't last very long
we're still alive technically mmm
always gonna turn you know what that is
so wait they're shooting at us right
here oh [ __ ] watch out yeah I don't know
okay 500s
coming Oh Russian yeah yeah Oh
and then a good time one-two punch
Oh another copy
when they jump Oh scares me
and look Nastia Liukin became a zombie
and all of a sudden that police officer
is not concerned with friendly fire
sorry did the girlfriend die yet behind
a counter staring at these guns should
easily be using unless they have those
triggers on that so maybe not do you
guys remember when my boyfriend died
the time ping doors clear what I said
now do that in the first place that guy
really sucks hello nice work down there
good news is I've got some folks coming
for me in a bus any minute now
if we can make it on board it's a
straight shot for toddlers also kind of
left 4 dead people are evacuating their
heard it on the radio that's a big if
it's a shitstorm out there we ain't
waiting for any stragglers cool
neither we Japanese dude he's like I'm
Korean there's a mo in this drawer over
here for me so I think this guy is is he
throwing
oh [ __ ] one of these things just came up
I kicked him is he dead
stay down I did that role thing
effectively I'm quite impressive
they still coming
this is a resident evil gamer playing if
it is surprising
oh man they're [ __ ] just floating in
here I'm switching to my shotgun
at two red herbs holy moly
just shut them originally by this window
and I have on that a green herb please
we're right next to me on the desk in
the new room what if when he did that
frustrated kick he opened it again on
accent yes right here yes thank you
oh [ __ ] you where did you come from I'm
gonna die
sorry
I was combining herbs really slowly
I'm wonder if we can go back to the
other room now no that doors yeah he
bought some the door probably could just
for more space I just needed like a
second sorry
[ __ ] I don't know let me do that me
[ __ ] let me combine those this goddamn
key I'm getting frustrated Mary it's HAP
okay here we go I'm healed oh they gave
us a full health back Oh
oh [ __ ] yeah come back to come back in
this room again I'm going to throw a
Nintendo at this [ __ ] the big tub of
[ __ ] kill her we don't care well I got a
remote bombs I have a remote bomb too
[Music]
wait who did he pick up the girl burnt
her I might have killed her sorry
no I'm not [ __ ] leaving without my
points everyone can go to hell what hold
on oh I'm getting all the stuff I'm
finishing my coffee work grenades in
here on the roof so did everyone make it
how's everybody feel a city as
Midwestern towns that get it bad
oh [ __ ] I got you
[ __ ] you you wouldn't let us say no I
guess they're doing it open look I'll
cover you
oh god it's another one of those things
cope gage son
oh you [ __ ] thank you I did that thing
again
firefighter oh sorry oh my god I didn't
wait a minute why did a firefighter have
something combustible in fact
firefighters don't carry flame throwers
they put out fire
I think the oxygen tank they keep on
their back flammable but really yes they
go into fire why would it be flammable
because it's really hard to pierce like
a scuba tank yeah are you making this up
no sound right
it's thing that I've seen in other video
games yes
that's what I'm basing this Yuri there
on the butts of your office no ticket
shoot him
wah director don't help him I'll be
right back oh [ __ ]
no guys gone wait it's not like you
saved me Oh
oh I got spit on Japanese guys daddy
oh yeah those guys are definitely better
Oh
dammit oh no got it
like making pasta
I hope you like grilled cheese pick one
of those and we can roll with it that
was cool check out my accuracy 69 really
so that could be the episode that's good
timing
but I will say we should see what the
skill situation is well press Start oh
it seemed we could spend secure points I
can't remember one who use those there
we go
okay so what would you recommend should
we have 11000 melee level at melee could
be good what is none mean you don't have
any equipped so you buy them on the
right side oh and then you can only have
three equipped at once yeah so defense
level one I'm gonna get that equip
what's square I'm gonna upgrade it you
can operate it once
are you like power during melee attacks
is pretty big slightly increases the
chance of scoring a critical hit
yeah it's called shooting him in the
face lock on studies hand when shooting
that's not bad I don't see these anymore
down oh there are increased strength of
attacks on a zombie reload your weapons
quickly damn I wish I had not spent
increases your combat gauge by three
blocks remove your targeting sight
increases your firepower and then these
are locked so I can't get them no matter
what yeah or no there no there you can
buy them they're locked money locked
cost more defeated enemies to drop items
that could be actually I'm gonna get bad
item drop that's what I got
we could if we're smart we could well oh
man no cuz that will affect you we have
a separator I'll do lone wolf incurious
keeps your partner oh they don't when
you don't want AI assistance allows you
to break free from the enemy's grasp
that's not terrible arrow pickup that's
a bit of spoiler
field medic I saved the last one I got
defense level one sweet I'm going to
increase my melee attack cost a lot but
I think it's worth it so really like me
laying dudes and then I put it on sweet
yay well I meant unless you want to get
another skill oh I only have 3000 I'm
gonna save it okay on the next knievel I
press Start just to make sure we saved
it okay I'm like options so start a
little back first scared
sorry don't forget to Like and subscribe
guys I'm going to turn the gameplay
volume down why I don't care we can
watch this in them see what's happening
next time yay
bus bus bus oh I've heard of those guys
that's all the news I thought now it's
your turn to help me come again and
Jason Statham who driving our bus Derek
C Simmons no that looks a lot like Jared
Leto I was just gonna say that I
remember that little pied son of a [ __ ]
you have something against Jared Leto I
take it no I just got these little
squinty eyes
wow it's just like that scene from
Jurassic Park to
I posit after this give a little will
tease the next episode you know I can't
pause no I know I'm just saying we read
up this
oh my god here's some dunce is getting
pulled out of the bus it's like the
beginning of uncharted 2
could I not reload
[Music]
but Oh brace yourself
just like address port too
[Music]
the best
oh do you see we hugged each other dead
yeah but in all fairness so should every
other zombie in the game we gotta
ejected from the bus you never to crash
on a bus before that's what they do
Jason now we'll never have crank four
other three who's gonna play you in the
expendable Mother bulb Jack dude
somebody call Vin Diesel we need to
replace him or the rock or Bruce Willis
I'm running out all shaved head action
stars ah yeh well Danny's gonna bottom
you know okay
Oh Howie Mandel yeah cool what ever
reason we're still alive boilers boilers
love doing that spoilers oh haha
all right no more spoilers spoilers see
you next time
I'm kaneen II he's got a shovel he's got
a shovel their shovels your face is a
show